when you look at your career are there
bits that you wrote whether in at the
Harvard Lampoon SNL your own late night
show yeah they're bits that stand out
that you wrote that you think are the
greatest like my greatest hits are they
think or do you just see it as one blur
it's kind of a blur I think uh the thing
I get maybe people ask me about the most
is this episode of The Simpsons I wrote
um the monorail episode and people
um Simpsons fans really like that
episode you wrote it yourself well
here's how it works and you got to be
clear about this I had the idea and you
know I think drafted it all drafted a
lot of like the major story points about
how the first part of the show is a
music man parody and the second part is
an Irwin Allen parody and here's what
happens but then you go into a room with
the most amazing writers and I'd start
to name them all but I'll forget someone
and they'll hate me but just you know
incredible VDS and Schwartz welders and
Reese and Gene and you know George Meyer
you go into this room Jeff Martin you go
into a room and they they uh they all
start throwing in great jokes and so
everything ultimately uh at the no one
can same can claim Soul credit for just
about anything on The Simpsons so but
that with the monorail episode that one
I get I that's that's uh and what's
really nice is when The Simpsons had a
big anniversary show at the Hollywood
Bowl James L Brooks asked me to come
back and sing the song from the monorail
episode with the Hollywood Gay Men's
Choir and it was one of the highlights
of my life it was just I mean Hollywood
Bowl packed me coming out dressed as the
music man singing this song that I wrote
when I had a Ford Taurus and bad skin
and I wrote it in a cramped little room
on the fox lot and thought it might
what's happening with Mike is where am I
going to become am I ever going to get
where I think I'm supposed to go and now
here I am singing this in front of
people in the at the Hollywood Bowl
satisfying magical and I I do try to
take those moments in you know